Hello Freak bitches ragdoll pull up.
Poor,
poor Mark Hunt fucking,
but mark has never been
the kind of grappling.
Steve Bay is way better at defending tape.
Oh No,
I think Steve Bay beach.
You know what?
If he punches steep in the face,
it's going to get more steam out
of his fucking he is and like not
coming back my last name that because
he's not going to come back and fight for
a world title right away.
I think it'd be all.
That was the biggest
embarrassed for the floor.
That would be a crazy for the biggest
fucking embarrassment of the year that you
would that be embarrassment.
But it was embarrassing.
But just come back with saying it.
We've got smart con.
They knew he was on the juice.
He went in there loaded to the gills.
It was just an imbalance.
Joe.
It was an embarrassing thing for everybody
and mark contact every fucking right
to be mad.
They put him in there with a guy
that's coming off rocket fucking fuel.
That dude don't just only deep ball.
What is the size of his fucking head?
He's taking shit that makes
you a fucking head grow.
Gets a fucking pit bulls.
I hope they put them against my yo check.
I will fly to fucking clean back gum.
It's climate con climate.
I found the snot in my nose.
It was bigger than this gum,
the Ed that I take the
gum out to eat it anyway.
Oh it was so long.
It was like a cookbook.
I got a flashback from the
hell that motherfucker.
Anyway,
cause I love him.
I love him.
From time to time I have a little pimple
and it just comes out like a stream and
it's got like a little clamp on board
with you with all this Steve Shit.
From time to time.
Oh when you eat,
when you do coke for 30 years,
it's a habit.
You'll wake up in the
morning and pick one out.
It's like a fucking candy cane with code.
You inhale that motherfucker.
It's like going to the dentist for free.
I will throw up on this fucking table.
I feel like
that's to be honest with ourselves.
We're all friends here.
That was the most embarrassing
fucking thing I ever seen.
I agree.
They knew he was on it and they
put that fucking animal in there.
Okay.
And you know what,
man?
Go ahead.
Keep doing those steroids.
Put them a Nigga and Spiel,
but whatever.
I love that Cleveland motherfucker.
Dude just got killed.
He killed him.
He'll fucking kill him.
And General Stevia think they would
ever be able to have him come off a
suspension and fight for the title.
That's not how it goes.
Oh,
$4 billion though.
Even scab off and Iranians head right now.
Right now.
They're fucking Shit Nigga though.
And we lost Ron.
Take the gum out of your mouth.
They lost Rhonda.
And the only other thing,
we got his fucking condom
and he's having a baby.
He don't want to fucking come back now.
You know what he's talking about.
He might come back,
but they don't want to give
him who he supposed to fight.
Who is he supposed to be supposed to
fight that silicon collar beep and happy
and have stories.
One of the let's do it.
Let's set it up.
No,
that's not
the shit.
You don't need to find out though.
He don't need to fight nobody.
He's number one,
right?
Or is this your boy number one?
It Tony Khabib's number.
Okay.
Then that's the fight NF.
However,
I will say had it not
been for the fat shaming,
I wouldn't have lost.
I'm going to guess I've
probably lost 30 pounds.
You do definitely look
better and feel better,
right?
Dude,
wait,
am I take off these lower layers?
I look so I feel so much better.
I feel I do.
I jogged eight miles today.
Like I just like,
that wasn't happening when I was two
50 some Thanksgiving outside or I don't
want my treadmill that
everything's on my treadmill.
I get in and do I watch
one of those rock rocks,
workout videos and get inspired?
The rock dude,
his workout videos are fucking awesome.
Do you not follow them on Instagram?
He's the best dude when he hit me up.
Do you,
does anyone remember this day in my life
I post,
I work out in the rock shirt.
I always have the rock shirt on,
which was the bull.
No,
it's the under Armour shirt.
Oh No,
they're not out yet.
They're coming out soon.
I'm getting all of the,
oh Geez.
I have a man crush on the rock.
He's also in a part of this thing
is finding inspiration and workout.
That credence Clearwater thing.
That's real.
That's what I do.
I play that to crank and then you
get on the thing and you're like,
fuck it.
Let's just start running.
Let them midnights past
show shine a lot on me.
What was it?
Kind of just the rock he,
anyway,
I would wear a shirt and I would,
it would,
I would do videos for the rock to
see and in the process I'd work out.
I'd work out because I'd want the rock cm.
Then he saw one and he was like,
I've made a video where I made a line.
I was like,
you know,
that's fine.
As I go,
I today I'm doing two a days.
For those of you who didn't
play football in high school,
two days,
for those of you who didn't
get pussy back in high school,
two days of what?
As bad as it did to put hair on our
balls and they loved it and he goes,
that too.
It is line had me Roland and then he goes,
team Bert.
I lost my shit,
but then I called him.
I go,
you never got,
you never did two a days and he goes,
I know I played baseball.
It's been the fucking funniest.
I want to do the Puerto Rican beard.
I'm going to fuck you.
Save it off.
Anyway,
just weird.
Just
tiles is here.
Beards?
Is that what that says is Macomeda beard
when I do comedy or where this year?
Beard Shit's funny.
Oh,
fucking poor guy.
the prince is beautiful.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what people just listening
have no idea why we're laughing.
This is fucking,
if you Google,
what is the,
give me the black and white one.
Jamie.
That profile one.
It's from the cover of what happened.
It's so bad.
It's super sculpted and it's got like
this like almost like a race track curve
to it.
It's really weird.
It's the weirdest fucking beer in October.
Can we just do like a
Puerto Rican guy beard?
It's just a line Puerto Rican guy.
Beard.
Yeah.
It said Puerto Rican facial hair.
Oh,
that's what's up,
dude.
You're getting,
that
is my new favorite thing.
Google black guy being black.
You can't talk.
He's playing lower scene.
It's a tiger.
Oh,
he has a tiger print beers.
Leopard.
Leopard print.
It's very thin.
Oh my God.
This golden blacks is amazing.
Yeah.
This dude has his hair bleached blonde
and dyed black in the shape of leopard
skin on his beard.
That was the closest I
came to blacking out.
I was laughing so hard I couldn't breathe.
Is that the guy from backstreet boys
that like might have been that hardest?
That's pretty close,
but I want to give you,
that might've been the hardest.
Physically I've ever lied.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.